last call if we have it Jason 617 830
4750 you are the last caller today who
am I talking to my name is dave i'm
calling from dallas texas how you doing
today we're doing great third Texas call
today interestingly enough what can we
do for you well last week y'all talked a
little bit about a CNN meteorologist
who's a climate change denier used to be
used to describe Chad Myers who used to
be a denier buddy since come around oh
well that's good to know i'm not must've
misunderstood i thought he was still a
climate change in our so what happened
is when i when i went on there bill nye
went on and referenced a climate change
denier and he was referring to Chad
Myers but after that Chad Myers
clarified no I understand the science
now I'm not a denier anymore that's good
well the reason I was actually called I
was one or if you guys have ever heard
of the urban heat island effect I'm
sorry if we've heard of the what you did
was just sort of low when you said that
the urban heat island effect i have not
what would it have you heard of that
jason i assume he's kind of referring to
how you know the the concrete jungle
effective he will wear the all the
pavement and all the black surfaces in
Hades city absorbs the heat and kind of
contains it is that what you were
referring to Dave that's that's exactly
what I was referring to weld on Jason
yeah no I you know where I mean
inception it makes a lot of sense I've
not heard of it but I'll absolutely look
into it well that's something
meteorologist actually that's a
phenomena they called the hedonic like
this an actual meteorological time you
know and so it makes me think if humans
can affect the temperature locally in
big cities like New York City Chicago
Boston where you live dallas-fort worth
what either you know better understand
the reason that when you have big cities
spread out all over the world that
collectively if they can affect the
temperature locally that collectively
they could affect the temperature of the
planet overall listen conceptually
that's absolutely possible i'm not a
climatologist i would need to to learn
more about it but conceptually speaking
there's there's probably something too
and we will absolutely look into it all
right Dave gotta run thank you so much
day from Dallas Texas they're checking
in with us a fairly big city in its own
right no doubt about it that will do it
for calls today we have a fantastic show
coming up after the break we will review
a truly classic interview that I
participated in and then we'll answer
some questions at the end of the show